chief congressional correspondent Nancy
Cordes is here with CBS news political
correspondent Edie O'Keefe Nancy will be
covering the Senate races tonight and Ed
will be watching the house contest but
of course both of you are experts in all
of the races you know let's start with
the Senate assuming that the Democrats
could hold on to Missouri and Indiana is
this a race that's gonna be fought in
the Sun Belt Arizona and Nevada yes I
mean that's certainly where Republicans
are most vulnerable you've got Dean
Heller of Nevada he's probably the most
vulnerable Senate Republican he
represents a state that went narrowly
for Hillary Clinton in 2016 so we'll be
watching that as a possible Democratic
pickup and then Jeff Flake retiring in
Arizona that becomes an open seat and so
you've got a very tight race there
between martha mcsalley the Republican a
congresswoman against Kyrsten Sinema her
fellow congresswoman the Democrat and
the polls there have been all over the
place sometimes one is up by five the
others up by six so that's gonna be a
really exciting race to watch it see one
of the earliest traces we're gonna know
something about is Indiana is that
important to you not just because it's
early but because it might mean
something else are there other races you
should look I mean I think that that is
a fascinating race to watch because Joe
Donnelly is one of the three most
endangered Democrats along with a Joe
Manchin of West Virginia and Heidi
Heitkamp of North Dakota Donnelly voted
against Cavanaugh for Supreme Court that
was a very difficult decision for him he
knew that that was going to be difficult
in a state like Indiana that went for
President Trump so overwhelmingly in the
presidential election the polls look
decent for him right now but you know
this is one of those states like
Tennessee like Texas where anything
could happen and then you put together
an hour-by-hour look at the races in the
congress's Nora said you guys both know
everything about everything
so what are you looking for tonight that
gives you an indication of how things
are gonna go the Democrats keep telling
us they have multiple ways to knit the
23 seats that they need to retake the
majorities you can look at a few early
states and get a sense of where they
might do quite well Virginia
Pennsylvania and New Jersey all three of
those if they win a majority of the
competitive races in those states
they're about halfway to the 23 before
10:00 p.m. Eastern tonight
Virginia ten just
said Washington and almost guaranteed
Democratic pickup if you believe the
polls if they win something like the
second District in Virginia down in
Norfolk then blue tsunami warnings may
be issued nationwide because that's the
kind of race that is a reach that
Republicans worry about that they could
conceivably win one of the most
important storylines tonight is not only
women on the ballot but women marching
to the polls right women voters and
women candidates I mean polls have
showed that women are walking away from
and in some cases running away from the
Republican Party so how pronounced is
that shift tonight and are women more
motivated to vote that's something that
we'll be able to see in our exit polls
and then beyond that this has been a
really extraordinary year for women
candidates 238 women on the ballot in
the house alone tonight that is a huge
uptick 167 just two years ago so right
now we've got 84 women currently serving
in the house if they have a great night
tonight they could surpass 100 a big
increase but that's still only 20-25
percent of the house women make up 51%
of the population an example of how they
could change the makeup of Congress
Pennsylvania right now has an all-male
delegation almost guaranteed that at
least one to maybe as many as five women
will join that delegation and the
president has had one constant theme
these past few weeks and that is
immigration immigration immigration if
Republicans do hold both houses will we
see immigration lips you'll see them
begin to push through as the campaign
signs say it is rally finish the wall
whether Democrats allow for that or if
there's some kind of a deal where
dreamers are legalized in the process
we'll see all right our experts edit
Nancy thank you so much continuous live
coverage of the midterm elections begins
on CBS M today at 5:00 p.m. for Central
and we'll all be here for primetime
election night special starting at 8:00
7:00 central right here on CBS